there is a prophecy for years warring
factions have sought the great unifier
he thought one of the Star Wars sequels
would do it but no some people actually
like the discourse rages there has been
no release until you my child you are
the unifier because you are
like the worst you're the worst you suck
well someone must defend me right the
conservatives hate you the Liberals
don't think you're funny people who
celebrate animation as a medium oh they
they especially hate you yeah but why
how can this be because you suck you
just you're not very good you're a bad
show for one second the world can be
unified behind a common enemy so like a
dumb Alien Invasion movie Independence
Day okay can you just stop making
pointless references it just gets
grading after a while you know just
don't sorry okay but best of all you
help me how do I help you hate watching
most that works